when the world needs saving it will take
the most elite team on earth skipper
Kowalski Rico and private were the
elitist of the elite ha ha
now the creators of Madagascar okay boys
this is it the mission we've been
preparing for our entire lives remain
calm
penguins you are now under the
protection of the Northwind rabbit
Dibble me the north wind is an elite
undercover interspecies a litt
undercover interspecies task for force
dedicated to her help dedicated
dedicated to helping animals and Kok
help themselves mmm skipper we've got to
be 5 miles up that pretty much limits
our options I make my own options
brilliant move skipper but now we seem
to be outside the play
I have care to get caught up in the
movement well hindsight's 2020 oh why
don't we catch that plane birdstrike log
it works Penguins of Madagascar
now we're talking let's get to work
400 meters 300 meters speak American
Kowalski sorry sir
218 yards okay then it's clear what we
need to do next that feels right